the 4th of July was the hottest year in
the world on record and then after that
the record was surpassed again and it
will be again I am open to skipping the
climate change conversation for today
just to tell you that there are so many
other important conversations we need to
have for example when Texas says that
they're going to do a big boy for
freedom and liberty and not connect
their electrical grid to any neighboring
grids like every other U.S state has
done and then it gets insanely hot and
then they have power outages because
people are running their ACS and then
vulnerable folks start to die from the
heat it's not a super impressive
conservative thing to do to say we're
going it alone and doing all of these
great things it's actually terrible